[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren
vielleicht ist dieser haushalt ja
tatsächlich der letzte den eine von
ihnen frau bundeskanzlerin geführte
bundesregierung vorlegt dem land und
seinen bürgern wäre das zu wünschen die
frage ist nur wie viel unheil wollen sie
in ihrer verbleibenden amtszeit noch
anrichten
die katastrophale bilanz dieses corona
jahres ihr planloser und grotesker
umgang mit der herausforderung durch das
saas sowie zwei virus lässt nichts gutes
ahnen
eine verlogene lockdown politik hat das
kürzlich ihr parteifreund der
staatsrechtler und verteidigungsminister
ag professor rupert scholz genannt einer
jener vernünftigen und qualifizierten
köpfe die in der von ihnen dominierten
partei keine chance mehr haben
auch nach einem dreivierteljahr stochern
sie immer noch im nebel und klammern
sich an die untaugliche
holzhammermethode lockte die meere
kolateralschäden anrichtet als nutzen im
kampf gegen das virus zu bringen
ihr bayrischer adlatus markus söder
greifen noch tiefer in die trickkiste
autoritärer herrschaft umwirft sogar mit
ausgangssperren um sich statt das
gebotene zu tun und gezielt die
besonders gefährdeten
bevölkerungsgruppen zu schützen sperren
sie die bürgerlichen existenzen treiben
ganze branchen in den ruinen und
versuchen bis an den wohnzimmertisch in
das privatleben der bürger
hineinzuregieren so kann es nicht
weitergehen
der staat kann auch nicht unbegrenzt
betriebe die faktisch mit berufsverbot
belegt wurden auf kosten der
steuerzahler entschädigen
das sagen sie ja sogar selbst dann
ziehen sie aber auch die konsequenzen
und beenden
die kontraproduktive lockdown politik
alles andere ist in den worten von
rupert scholz verlogen die zur
untätigkeit verurteilt und vom ruin
bedrohten gewerbetreibenden durften
gerade erst jetzt erfahren dass die
großartig versprochenen november hilfen
wohl erst irgendwann im januar war noch
ein software-tool fehlt so viel zur
digitalisierung die sie seit jahr und
tag im munde führen ohne dass sich etwas
tut
schnell sind sie aber mit
milliarden-hilfen nur bei großen
konzernen die sie im gegenzug sukzessive
unter staatskontrolle bringen alle paar
wochen maß sich ihre von der verfassung
nicht vorgesehenen kugelrunde mit dem
ministerpräsidenten an neue
widersprüchliche und über griffige
massnahmen zu verhängen
oben drauf haben sie noch mit einem
fragwürdigen euphemistisch als
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz ausgegebenen
konstrukt einen blankoscheck ausstellen
lassen um das parlament zu umgehen und
das übrigens anders als die auszahlung
der november hilfen an nur einem tag
über die bühne und durch alle instanzen
gebracht bürger die gegen ihre maßnahmen
politik protestieren werden als
extremisten diffamiert mit dem
verfassungsschutz bedroht und mit
wasserwerfern und polizei gewalt
auseinandergetrieben sie sind es frau
bundeskanzlerin die dieses land und
diese gesellschaft spalten gelenkte
wirtschaft und demokratie
ein verarmter mittelstand aus hinters
licht geführten selbstständigen und
gewerbetreibenden eingeschüchterte
bürger das ist das ergebnis ihrer
politik am horizont ziehen
massenarbeitslosigkeit und bislang nicht
gekannte pleite wellen auf dazu kommt
ein abnorm hohe schuldenberg für die
vermeintlichen geschenke die sie damit
im kommenden wahljahr verteilen wollen
werden künftige generationen noch
mehr zu bezahlen haben diese bilanz
allein dürfte schon reichen um ihre
kanzlerschaft als katastrophal in die
geschichte eingehen zu lassen aber das
ist nur der gipfel die schwersten
grundrechtseingriffe seit bestehen der
deutschen nachkriegsdemokratie
die sie zu verantworten haben reihen
sich nahtlos an die drei fundamentalen
rechtsbrüche die auf immer mit ihren
regierungsjahren verbunden bleiben
werden erstens die transformation der
währungsunion in eine haftungs und
schulden union zweitens die
industrialisierung und wohlstands
vernichtung durch energiewende auto
wende kohle und atom ausstieg drittens
die unkontrollierte einwanderung unter
missbrauch des asylrechts nach 15 merkel
jahren ist deutschland ein land das
seine grenzen nicht gegen illegale
einwanderung schützen will aber seine
bürger mit ausgangssperren überzieht und
heerscharen von polizisten zur kontrolle
der masten pflicht im zugverkehr
abkommandiert also bitte in den 15
jahren ihrer kanzlerschaft haben sie
verspielt was ihnen ihre amtsvorgänger
an reformen kapital hinterlassen haben
die fehler der vorgängerregierung haben
sie nicht korrigiert sondern
verschlimmert dass deutschland das sie
hinterlassen ist tief gespalten in
seinen grundlagen erschüttert und weit
nach links abgedriftet aus einem
leidlich sicheren land mit
funktionierender wirtschaft und stabile
energieversorgung ist
land des misstrauens geworden in dem die
straße nicht mehr sicher sind und
importierte kriminalität und
islamistischer terror zur alltäglichen
bedrohung geworden sind es ist ein land
der widersprüche geworden die bundeswehr
ist unter ihrer regierung zwar gender
sensibel geworden aber kaum noch
einsatzfähig
dafür sehen polizisten immer häufiger
die soldaten aus wenn aber in berlin
oder essen einen klaren krieg ausbricht
sind die beamten zum zuschauen
verdonnert bis ein muslimischer
friedensrichter aus der migrantischen
parallel justiz den streit geschlichtet
hat unsere nachbarländer ergreifen im
krieg gegen den islamistischen terror
die initiative in deutschland wird mit
phrasen beschwichtigt und lieber noch
eine milliarde für den kampf gegen
rechts ausgegeben frauen trauen sich
nachts nicht mehr auf die straße aber
die regierung regelt akribisch wer will
zu weihnachten besuchen darf und wer
nicht die industrielle basis bröckelt
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze sind schon
weggefallen oder ins ausland verlagert
industrie feindliche politik ist die
ursache die korona krise hat die
entwicklung beschleunigt und verschärft
da los nimmt diese regierung hin
das absurde eu grenzwerte der deutschen
automobilindustrie den gar ausmachen
ergebnis jahrelanger auto hasser politik
die premiumhersteller bmw und daimler
verlegen den bau von verbrennungsmotoren
wohin ins ausland hochtechnologie in
deutschland erfunden und perfektioniert
wandert zulieferer und gut bezahlte jobs
werden folgen elektromobilität die auch
durch noch so horrende subvention auf
absehbare zeit nicht wettbewerbsfähig
wird ist dafür
kein ersatz von wird es auch nie sein im
namen der klimaschutz hysterie schließen
in deutschland modernste kohlekraftwerke
und sichere atommeiler
dafür wird dann kohle und atomstrom aus
dem ausland importiert wenn in den
windrad wäldern die unsere landschaft
verschandeln und raubvögel erschlagen
wieder mal flaute herrscht gäbe es war
absurd ist die idee kommt von rot grün
in hamburg buchholz aus namibia zu
importieren um es in deutschland zu
feuern das ist olaf stolz herum turf was
haben wir anderes erwarten
bürger und unternehmen bezahlen für
diese wirtschaftspolitische kakophonie
mit den höchsten energiepreise und
steuern und abgaben lasten aller
industrieländer
obwohl die deutschen am privatvermögen
und rentenniveau weit hinter den meisten
euro-ländern zurückliegen dürfen sie
demnächst für weitere milliarden
transfers in die südlichen krisenstaaten
zahlen hinter dem vorhang der korona
krise haben sie nämlich auch das verbot
der vergemeinschaftung von
staatsschulden weiter aufgebrochen die
eurobonds heißen jetzt corona
wiederaufbau fonds in diesen tagen
entscheidet sich ob großbritannien die
eu mit oder ohne brett vertrag verlässt
den ausschlag für den eu austritt des
vereinigten königreichs gab der
kontrollverlust in der bis heute
ungelösten migrations krise mit dem sie
einen tiefen keil zwischen die europäer
getrieben haben die briten haben das
nicht vergessen
während diese regierung die grundlagen
unseres wohlstands und terminiert brummt
in china schon wieder die wirtschaft
gehen chinesische staatsfonds auf
einkaufstour im gebeutelten deutschen
mittelstand schafft peking die größte
freihandelszone der welt in deutschland
beschäftigen wir uns derweil lieber mit
der frauenquote in
unternehmensvorständen radikal linke da
rechnen wir schon richtig radikal linke
ideologien wie gender
liegen oder der kommunistische
kampfbegriff antifaschismus sind in den
mainstream gerückt während konformismus
und gesinnungs druck sozialistischer ihr
glaube und planwirtschaftlicher waren
eine absurde wiederauferstehung erleben
auch das gehört zu verteilen die last
ihrer regierungszeit in der tat frau
merkel sie sind die beste kanzlerin die
grüne und linke hatten die begeisterung
die man von ihnen dort entgegen bringt
ist der beste beleg und es schmerzt mich
was aus diesem land geworden ist und wir
sind angetreten um diese schieflage zu
korrigieren wir wollen erreichen dass
recht gesetz und verfassung überall und
unbedingt gelten und nicht nach belieben
zurecht gebogen und ignoriert werden
dass freiheit und eigenverantwortung der
bürger im mittelpunkt der politik stehen
und nicht bevormundung in immer weitere
lebensbereiche
unser ziel ist dass staat und verwaltung
sich auf ihre kernaufgaben konzentrieren
das heißt die gewährleistung des
rechtlichen und ordnungspolitischen
rahmens und die aufrechterhaltung der
inneren und äußeren sicherheit und nicht
die ständige und übergriffige
einmischung in das privatleben und die
wirtschaftlichen entscheidung der bürger
frau merkel kommen sie heraus aus ihrem
geistigen bomlitz blicken sie über den
tellerrand ihres kanzleramts das in
schweren krisenzeiten für 600 millionen
euro vergrößern wollen und schauen sie
sich an wie es wirklich aussieht in
diesem land hören sie damit auf sich in
ihrer filter blase aus politischen und
medialen schmeichler das eigene versagen
schön zu reden und sich für ihre
irrtümer auch noch feiern zu lassen
die wahrheit ist den menschen zumutbar
hat ingeborg bachmann einmal treffend
gesagt
zur wahrheit gehört aber auch dieses
land kann sie und ihre politik nicht
mehr lange aushalten
ich bedanke alles weide war dass die
hier die debatte eröffnete die auf die
fraktionsvorsitzende am mittwoch in ein
haus als woche gibt es die sogenannte
generaldebatte das ist die chance für
die opposition mit der politik der
bundesregierung abzurechnen das ist auch
das einzige mal dass die opposition als
erstes hier das rederecht im hohen hause
hat darauf antwortet traditionell die
kanzlerin wobei das schon mal gesagt sie
muss nicht auf nummer zwei reden sie
könnte auch später in der debatte das
wort ergreifen das hat angela merkel
noch nie getan helmut kohl kann ich mich
erinnern im bonner zeiten hat
gelegentlich erst als sechster oder
siebter gesprochen